I have been out of six week break from chemo because of terrible neuropathy from the chemo.
In the last six weeks, my uncle had phosphatase, a shot up to 268 by ALT to 361 by AST to
1951.
Six weeks ago, they were normal or dear normal.
The only change I made during this time was to start taking SEACT.
Do you think the SEACT would be causing this increase?
My ecologist thinks it's the cancer, but he does not know about me taking the SEACT.
Anything is possible.
So if you have elevation of alkaline phosphatase, but you don't have elevation of ALT and AST,
then you don't think that it's still possible, but it's a little lesser degree chance that
it's something going on at the liver itself.
You start thinking of tissue damage elsewhere.
So if you have a known cancer, you look at if my alkaline phosphatase is elevated by
ALT and AST is spared, then you think that it's the most common thing you would see.
If you have ALT elevated, AST elevated, like this question along with alkaline phosphatase,
then you think the irritation or the problem is in the liver itself.
So I would say that yes, it's possibly the SEACT could be something in that herb combination
that your liver just doesn't like.
I would for sure test that by just going off of that.
Could it be the cancer?
Well, if it is the cancer, it would be more likely that the cancer is metastasis to the liver
than it is because the cancer is growing in the breast or growing in the lung or growing
in the intestinal tract or even metastasized to bone because typically, if you have cancer
growing in any of those things I just mentioned or metastasized to bone, it wouldn't increase
ALT and AST.
So again, the most common reason for increased alkaline phosphatase ALT and AST is the drug
as a medication, even Tylenol, pain medication will do that.
So if you're not at 80 medications whatsoever, the only change you made is SEACT that I would
say, well, I would definitely go off SEACT and see if it decreases.
If you, let's say, if it has nothing to do with cancer, it has something to do with irritation
of the liver because something you're taking, and let's say it was SEACT and you went off
of it, these numbers should come back to normal relatively quickly.
Or if it was Tylenol, all I'm taking Tylenol every day, well, if you were able to get off
of that, these numbers should go down.
So I would investigate anything you're taking could be, it's very common that Tylenol does
this.
So if you're taking something like that or other pain medication or ad bill, but definitely,
if you're not taking any of those things, I would go off the SEACT and then wait a few
weeks and see if the numbers stabilize or start to decrease.
This elevated ALT, AST and Oakland Foss, not taking Tylenol or any other painkillers,
that I would definitely suspect SEACT, I would, you know, if a person, there wasn't taking
anything and they had a diagnosis of cancer and they had a rapid increase in those three
liver markers, you do, I would agree with the oncologist, you'd suspect metastasis to
the liver.
If you, or if you had no metastasis to the liver, you'd suspect, you know, an increase activity
in the liver, that's what you'd suspect.
If you don't have metastasis to the liver right now, then I wouldn't necessarily jump
to that.
I'd say, well, I did change and I took this different supplement or something, or you're making
a comment, I have had metastasis to the liver for over two years with normal numbers.
Then if you have no metastasis to the liver, then I would then switch my answer to, I might
agree with the oncologist that you might want to get a CT or MRI, whatever they used to
see the size of the lesions in the liver before because that's a greater possibility than
the SCAC doing that, so if you're a oncologist, if he's wanting to get imaging, I think I might
agree with that, that might be a good idea.